the revenant is directed by Alejandro
Gonzalez Inarritu
thank you very much Birdman for winning
all those awards last year because you
helped me learn how to maybe sorta
pronounce his name this is the true
story of a fur trapper named Hugh glass
played by Leonardo DiCaprio who in the
1820s is left for dead in the wilderness
and sets out on a path of revenge to
find those responsible for leaving him
in that position I'm just gonna say this
right off the bat the revenant has some
of the best cinematography these eyes
have ever seen there are shots in this
movie where I genuinely do not
understand how they got them and I mean
that with sincerity
there are moments throughout this very
lengthy runtime in which I gazed in awe
at some of the shots they were able to
accomplish and what's even more
impressive is that this entire film was
shot with natural lighting
there's no studio lights used in this
film they use fire they use the Sun they
used real shadows cast by the forest and
the trees the work they accomplished is
stunning I know how hard it is to create
even a semblance of an okay shot using
studio lights attempting to make an
entire film like that with just a
wilderness and very remote locations
it's mind-boggling to even think about
doing and it paid off because this is
one of the best looking films I've ever
seen but beyond the style is there any
substance to this film there are
attempts to get very surreal and
dreamlike with strange imagery that
doesn't always make sense I like movies
that are like puzzles where you have
scattered pieces that you have to try to
assemble and figure out what it's about
as Leo DiCaprio was crawling around in
the dirt and trying to survive he often
blacks out and has these strange dreams
where he's haunted by events of his past
and it doesn't always come across very
clear it does come across pretentious
sometimes it's also very long at two and
a half hours and the second act can get
a little repetitive that's it the rest
of this movie
I pretty much loved this is a brutal
disturbing violent movie in which one
man is pitted against nature and nature
is not playing nice and Leo DiCaprio was
great in this movie he has very minimal
dialogue and some of it isn't even in
the English language he was really good
this is some of the best work I've seen
from him and this
guy has done everything at this point
he's consistently surprising as an actor
and I loved his performance in this
movie let's talk a little bit about Tom
Hardy who's also in this movie because
without spoiling anything I'll say that
he is in a way directly related to Leo's
path of vengeance he is dead center in
DiCaprio's path of revenge and he's also
very good although he does fall back on
what I called the Tom Hardy mumble
directed a Mad Max
water give me water I love Tom Hardy in
movies I really do not just as an actor
whenever I see him in interviews and the
stuff he does with charities and stuff
the guy's a boss there were just a lot
of moments in this movie where I was
like huh but the eventual war that
starts between these two men was
riveting in fact it culminated in
something that was just white knuckled I
mean I was just gripping the seat and it
was fantastically hound and extremely
brutal and very exciting this movie
never flinches it is realistic and
gritty and you will never ever want to
hike in the woods if you see the
revenant ever again and guys you know me
no spoilers but there is a scene in this
film involving a bear and it is an
amazing achievement I just I don't know
how they did it I have no clue this is a
gorgeously shot movie with terrific
acting brutal action and amazing
camerawork that I genuinely couldn't
figure out it's very rare for me to go
to a movie nowadays in which I leave
going how did they do that
Mad Max fury road had some of those
moments as well as the revenant both Tom
Hardy movies good job Hardy are picking
good projects this movie had many scenes
that I honestly have no idea how they
accomplished it I'm going to give the
revenant an a-minus guys definitely
check out the revenant when it comes out
it does get a little pretentious with
its imagery and it is over long but it
is a gorgeous movie and definitely one
worth seeing guys thank you so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
man eyes